Okay, so let us uh implement linear
regression in a neural network form and
um we are going to use PyTorch in our
implementation because you already did
uh linear regression in numpy and other
frameworks. So we are going to use this
as an excuse uh to work with PyTorch uh
tensors. Uh however we are going to do
other things mostly from scratch.
Okay, so linear regression as you know
is a model that assumes a linear
relationship between the features X and
target Y. Like I said for now we are
assume scalar Y. This is the form that
we are looking at and the last function
is uh a mean square error. We already
discussed that in the previous lecture
and uh the gradient will be computed uh
using this equations and here let's
start with the code so like I said we
are going to use torch and what else we
want we may need some butting so let's
use ML lip we want this to be
reproducible let's fix the seating in
our generators let's make a synthetic
data
Uh to do that I'm going to write a
function here.
So let's just leave this for now. Okay.
So we want the to basically have the
model. So the arguments of the function
will be of course the the weights, the
bias
and the number of samples and uh
basically some form of noise that will
be added. And we are going to use just
standard Gaussian noise. We want the
function to return
uh the feature matrix for us and uh the
target uh vector looking at something
like this.
Okay. So basically we have the weights
and we have the biases the n sample is
simple
small galsian noise and this will give
us the the feature and return the
features and of course the predictions
or the target vector to make things
maybe more obvious here. This is really
a good practice in coding. Maybe not in
Python. It's not critical for Python but
uh just having the types that we are
going to expect this variable to have uh
and determining them here in the
function will make it more readable and
later you will see it will make your
debugging much easier. So we have bias
samples and noise.
So bias will be
Good. And like I said, we are expecting
this to give us the features and
prediction.
The features will be a torch tensor and
the prediction of course will be another
torch tensor. Okay. Note that here it
doesn't really recognize this. Uh what
does that mean? It means that I haven't
defined what's tupal. So I have to
import this from the typing.
So let's go back here. See everything
looks okay for now. And now we can go on
writing our function. Okay. As you see I
already have a a suggestion here. I'm
going to just use this because again I
assume that you know most of this stuff.
So d here is the the shape or the length
of the uh weights. Uh you could use just
len of weights. Like I said, weights is
a it's a vector. So you could do that.
Uh but this is more general in the sense
that sometimes we have multiple
uh y and y is not a scalar is a vector
itself. So we have like for example two
values for y not just one scale. And
this is a more uh general case. So X is
the feature matrix uh which is basically
the value of T features in each one of
these samples. And num samples is either
the entire data set size or maybe the
batch size later. We will talk about
that. And noise here is just a randomly
generated noise of course with for added
for each one of these uh synthetic data
samples. And then this is basically what
we get uh as the ground truth for y.
Remember this is synthetic data. Uh
let's go on and write our linear
regression. Okay. So let's write it as a
class. Okay. So going to just describe
what I want to do and for now like I
said we are using our manually derived
gradients
and with that let me just write this
down okay so just uh remember in
practice we really we don't need this
one these two cuz later on this will be
multiplied by the uh learning rate so
okay so this is the class that we want
to write we need an init method of
course and let's write that needs the
input size. Okay, what do we have here?
Uh we don't need num feature we have we
need the learning rate of course. So
let's just write input size which we
have a integer and a learning rate right
so I already see that here so and we
have float and so let's even make it
even uh the random weights I want them
to be even smaller and this is learning
rate and like I said since we don't have
autocrat and that's the input
Okay, so that's that. We have our init
method. We could uh add some print
statements. Uh maybe later, but for now,
let's just go with this. Now, what we
want? We want uh a forward pass, right?
We want this to compute the the
predictions given our current u
features, right? And this will return
our linear computation. You tab here.
That's it. This is our forward pass.
Basically computes the the values of y,
the output of the neural network, right?
Okay. What else we want? We want a
function that computes lots, right? So,
let's do that, too. Okay. I see the
suggestion looks okay to me. I'm going
to use that.
And notice that uh this can be really a
static method. I'm not sure if you
recall that. So I could just use a
static method here uh with a decorator
but for now let's just go with this. Now
we want to compute our gradient steps
and let's see what we have. Um okay self
x and this gives me yep this sounds
good. Okay.
Um so let's write this up. I'm going to
just write an error here. um and make
this more explicit, right? It will be
easier for you guys to see. Okay, so
that's how we compute the gradients and
we have to compute the step sizes,
right? Uh using this gradients. So we
need another function here. Like I said,
later we will see that your life will be
much easier. So let's do this. uh we
need the x
and y
and this uh will give us the step size
which is a float right so let's just
write so what we need for this one
gradient distance decent update we need
to compute the forward pass and then
compute the loss and then compute the
gradients and then update the parameters
so these are the steps that we want okay
good So let's write them. So like I said
first let's do
which is why I had
and two loss
and three the gradients of uh weights
and biases. So something that I skipped
here right maybe I should have
explained. So remember that um the the
gradient of the the bias is basically
the average error and that's how we
ground the error to zero to move it to
the origin if you remember. Okay. So
with that now we have the gradients the
weights and biases and we need to use
that for our updates right is a more com
compact notation. So this is it. We
update the weights and this also returns
the the loss. Okay, this looks good,
right? And now um next we can go toward
our stoastic gradient descent which
requires u to make mini patches. Right,
that's the next step. Let's make some
mini batches. Okay, so what we need? We
need X and Y and some batch size to
choose. And like I said, we need to
shuffle them, right? Maybe not.
Sometimes we don't need to necessarily,
but let's uh keep it as an argument.
Okay, so we have X, Y, B says, and
shuffle. Okay, so what does this
returns? It will return a generator if
you remember. So basically
uh actually maybe generator is not the
best option maybe we can use iterator
right uh generator is uh more common and
the reason is uh you have more control
uh but here the reason that I'm not
writing generator is uh you have some
extra arguments that I would want to
talk about them for now uh so let's use
an iterator
and iterator basically returns uh the
the two outputs. This basically yields
all of these badges of X's and Y's.
And uh here uh we have to shuffle them.
If shuffle,
we want to keep this torch.
If not shuffle, we just stick with what
you have. Okay.
dx basically give the the x and y in
each batches. So this is how we are
doing this for start in the range of
zero and n the step size of batch. Okay.
So what will be the end and will be the
start pro plus the batch size right and
uh since sometime we may hit the button
so uh we have to use the minimum of that
or
last we just need to enter the range of
the the batches. So let's just use
um the indices start to end, right?
Okay. So with that we just need to
uh our generator to yield XP and white.
Okay, good. Um so this is uh how we are
making the mini patches and now we can
train the model. Okay, let's write this.
So it takes in the the model which is
the class that we have uh x and y and uh
we still need to enter the batch size.
So model
x
number of impacts and batch sizes. So we
use 32.
So let's return some form of average
loss across the the apo which will be a
float really decent and this is the
training group
and we are reporting the average loss
right so in each one of these epochs so
we have the epoch averages
like I said it's a list of floats
And for now it's empty. Um so for each
uh we wait let's see what we have here.
We for each epoch. So basically this uh
this is the last that we get in each
batch and and the model already took a
step using this uh batches uh toward a
better parameter. So the training is
done but we promised here that we are
going to return some average loss per
epoch. So let's then add up
uh all of these losses that we are
collecting in each epoch. Let's change
this name. So this is the total loss per
that epoch. And we since we calculating
the average um
on fly we need to have an counter here.
Let's just put a counter here. Maybe
number of batches. So this is the okay
that's it. Now for that debug we can
compute the average.
I I just I'm I'm just scared of this
when it starts from zero. Let's just be
careful. uh doesn't hurt. We don't want
to have division by zero. So, uh we can
add some verbose messaging here.
Training
and model. Yeah.
Oops. So, you see that this is not
defined. We have to define this too. So,
verbose is just a boolean and let's say
default is true. Okay. So what we want
to print out um if variables
we want to print out the maybe the model
parameter and I see there are some
suggestions uh but since we wanted to if
you remember we are synthetic data we
had some ground truth we can write that
out too and maybe compare it with the
ground truth so let's just add this here
now we want to
make uh some synthetic data using our
function.
Let's start with maybe a small
two-dimensional
uh
weight. So the true weight and let's
just choose two values. Okay,
let's have a true list. Let's generate
1,00 sample from this
and then this way we can basically run
the generate synthetic data.
We have the model which is a linear
and then we have the input size. Uh
let's just not change the learning rate
and we just need to train it. Right? So
I want to separate these things out. So
let's keep this here.
And
so I mean we really can
title this off for now because we are
doing it anyways here.
Okay. So let's run our happy little
code.
What's happening here? Um currently here
the learning rate which is a correctly a
tensor of this shape is multiplying by
a two by 1,000
tensor.
This is strange because if you remember
1,00 is the number of total
uh generated samples and then later we
basically work with much smaller
batches. So I didn't expect that um
there might be an error somewhere that
uh propagated and cascaded here. One
thing that you should remember often
when PyTorch is trying to align tensors
uh together maybe during multiplication
or even summation
uh when we don't explicitly
determine like the the dimensions we
have to be careful so let's just take
this here I want to compare it to the
error here so okay so what do we expect
Here weight is a column, right? So, and
we multiply it by X. X is of course a
1,00 by 2. We expect a 1,00
2 matrix multiply by
a column of size two. Uh
so the answer will be a vector with this
size.
And then later when we add this to the
bias or noise which is now a th00and one
this is where
uh pytorch must uh be creative
to expand the dimension
not necessarily reduce.
So since it doesn't know how is this
happening instead of adding a one here
it actually does this which returns
instead of what we expected right so we
don't want that uh to let pytorch make
this decisions for us so to avoid that
we are going to cast this weights into
the form that we know basically whatever
is the first
uh dimension. We want the second
dimension to be one by I don't care
what's the first dimension. I want this
to be one. Okay, so instead of saying I
don't care, put minus one. Okay, it's a
placeholder really. It's not really
literally minus one. Okay, so let's do
this change and go back. See if our life
gets any better. Okay. So that's that
and went with that. Let's try everything
again. Something else happened. Oh yeah,
of course.
So we we came till here. That's great.
And the last line cannot print this.
Why? Because basically we are saying
that this should be fine because the
tensor is now least and we can print
this. But the tensor here is still a
tensor and we are saying that printed in
a float that's not happening. So let's
just tell that we want this to be the
item
or the value of the tensor. Okay. So
with that let's run again. We are good.
So later we will do the same code but
with uh backward and auto div and more
uh tools instead of writing it from
scratch. Okay. So uh let's um
plot the uh the training loss and uh
here I wrote a function for that uh that
basically takes in the model and it
plots the the loss history the amount of
loss per each one of these batches. So
let's make sure we have that uh we
append all of these loss values here the
step. So let's do that. So we need a
self assessor, right? And I see that we
don't have it. It means that we haven't
initialize it. So we have to do that
first.
Let's keep that.
And here subass history.
And we want to append all of that. And
good. And let's train everything again.
And now we can plot and we are plotting
the model right that's it and you see
that the loss is going down with the
training.